this was very interesting this was one
of the more interesting moments of the
evening he claimed that Republicans
wanted to get rid of Social Security but
watch as he says it he's kind of telling
you that he knows it's not true he has a
little bit of a tell and then a bunch of
Republicans in the audience started
yelling
czar
instead of making the wealthy pay their
fair share some Republicans
some Republicans want Medicare and
Social Security Sunset I'm not saying
it's a majority
let me give you anybody who doubts it
contact my office I'll give you a copy
I'll give you a copy of The Proposal
that means Congress doesn't vote
well I'm glad to see you no I tell you I
enjoy conversion
the program's the way they are they go
away other Republicans say I'm not
saying it's a majority of you I don't
even think it's even a significant
but it's being proposed by individual
I'm not politely not naming them but
it's being proposed by some of you
look
folks
the idea is that we're not going to be
we're
so he goes out of his way at first to
imply that it's the Republicans that
want to do this then it's some
Republicans then respectfully it's
somebody but I don't want to name them
anything else there you had I mean you
saw Marjorie Taylor green she's thought
of as sort of like on the really right
right the far right side of the
Republican Party the Trump wing of the
Republican party and there she is
screaming you're a liar that's not what
we want to do Kevin McCarthy is shaking
his head no I don't know any mainstream
Republican that is looking into cutting
Social Security do they talk about how
entitlements are costing us too much
money do they talk about rampant
government spending yes he also of
course links this to if we could just
take more money from rich people and by
the way rich people people making well
certainly over a million dollars but
even people making over a hundred
thousand dollars pay virtually all the
taxes the bottom 50 percent pay
virtually nothing and it's never an
income issue for the government it's a
spending issue right it's that they
spend like drunken sales dollars uh it's
like they they spend like crack addicts
trying to get more parmesan cheese out
of the carpet as opposed to saying oh
maybe let's spend a little less so we
have to just take less from other people
but in the Democrat mind in the Biden
mind we just need more money from those
people producing stuff who often the
people producing stuff and making money
they often spend money and hire people
and then those people build businesses
and that's kind of how the whole thing
really is designed to work but if we can
just centralize more of their money and
do what we want with it it would be good
so anyway it was nice to see you know I
keep saying
that Republicans or get involved
[Music]